lo hemos contado ya aquí en visual
política argentina es algo así como el
país donde el fútbol es prácticamente
una religión de estado y donde no pasa
una sola década sin que se produzca al
menos una gran crisis económica durante
décadas este país ha estado dominado por
un modelo político una especie de
ideología una corriente política el
peronismo que es algo así como la suma
de nacionalismo proteccionismo y gasto
público
nosotros
y cuando hablo de nosotros hablo del
movimiento político al que pertenezco
yo si el peronismo sí
pero en 2015 llegó un nuevo gobierno el
de mauricio macri con la misión de
reconstruir el país de arriba abajo yo
mauricio macri juro por dios nuestro
señor y estos santos evangelios
desempeñar
con lealtad y honestidad
el cargo de presidente de la nación
argentina en las elecciones legislativas
de 2017 el pueblo argentino ha
revalidado su confianza en este proceso
por decirlo de alguna forma le ha venido
a decir bien hecho macri así que amigos
la pregunta que empieza a estar en el
aire es esta argentina por fin de una
vez por todas lista para despegar
veámoslo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el pasado 22 de octubre de 2017 se
celebraron elecciones al congreso y al
senado en argentina la coalición del
gobierno cambiemos con más de 10
millones de votos tuvo un triunfo
aplastante ganó en 15 de los 24
distritos electorales incluyendo los 5
principales los más poblados la
provincia de buenos aires- la ciudad de
buenos aires córdoba santa fe y mendoza
no ocurría algo así ni más ni menos que
desde 1985
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ahora tras estas elecciones cambiemos
está cerca de la mayoría absoluta lo que
le asegura al gobierno poder sacar
adelante su agenda de reformas hoy
estamos acá no porque estemos en contra
de nadie nosotros nosotros somos
antinada y estamos a favor de nuestro
futuro porque creemos que merecemos
vivir mejor
[Aplausos]
por eso amigos o muchos los analistas
que afirman que ahora comienza de verdad
el mandato de macri ahora bien tras dos
años en el poder que ha hecho mauricio
macri que no ha hecho cuáles son sus
intenciones realmente puede argentina
convertirse en el país de moda lo vamos
a ver en este vídeo pero antes veamos un
poquito de historia
[Música]
el declive
y
hace un siglo argentina era uno de los
países más ricos del mundo más rico
incluso que países como canadá australia
francia o la mismísima alemania y no
sólo eso el 8 de mayo de 1945 al
terminar la segunda guerra mundial
argentina era junto a eeuu uno de los
mayores acreedores mundiales y también
uno de los mayores propietarios de oro
de todo el planeta
en aquel momento amigos buenos aires-
estaba en pleno auge y era capaz de
rivalizar con la mismísima nueva york'
algo que os aseguro queda muy claro
cuando visitáis esta fantástica ciudad
por primera vez pero claro dicho esto
puede que te estés preguntando qué
diantres le ocurrió a la argentina
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pues mira a pesar de que las cosas para
este país no pintaban nada mal tras la
segunda guerra mundial lo cierto es que
algo estaba ya cambiando
[Música]
la gran crisis internacional de los años
30 afectó mucho al país argentina que
era un gran exportador de productos
agrícolas sufrió la debacle del comercio
internacional y su primera gran crisis
financiera desde entonces nada volvió a
ser lo mismo
la política amigos comenzó a intervenir
todos los campos de la economía y la
sociedad y finalmente en 1946 comenzó lo
que podemos llamar el viraje definitivo
el gobierno de general fue el primero y
del coronel juan domingo perón después
aprobaron todo tipo de normas y leyes
ojo más de 16.000 decretos leyes que de
facto pusieron a la economía bajo el
control del estado
[Música]
y cosas como el comercio exterior la
creación de empresas o la competencia
quedaron en un segundo plano en su lugar
políticas como la sustitución de
importaciones las nacionalizaciones o
las grandes empresas estatales fueron el
patrón dominante en esa nueva argentina
[Música]
y así comenzó amigos toda una cuesta
abajo de 70 años que hizo que argentina
se convirtiese en uno de los pocos
países que ha pasado de ser un país
desarrollado a ser un país en vías de
desarrollo conceptos como crisis
hiperinflación o suspensión de pagos han
sido temas muy pero que muy habituales
en los medios de comunicación de este
país en las últimas décadas y este
proceso tuvo como colofón al
kirchnerismo especialmente en su última
etapa en la de cristina fernández de
kirchner
[Música]
como arruinar un país
a lo largo de sus dos mandatos como
presidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner puso en pie un modelo que
podría definirse sencillamente como anti
económico si argentina ya era un país
terrible para hacer negocios pero con
christina fue un paso más allá
argentina de cfk había controles de
capitales las empresas no podían
repatriar sus beneficios los impuestos a
las empresas alcanzaron proporciones no
comparables en latinoamérica había
muchísimas restricciones a las
importaciones y el banco central se
dedicó a darle a la máquina de crear
dinero para financiar al gobierno
y el modelo era tan terriblemente
antieconómico amigos que cristina puso
un montón de impuestos a las
exportaciones tal cual como lo escucháis
a quién se le puede ocurrir castigar a
las empresas que se dedican a exportar a
vender a otros países de locos
uno mira y ve que el mundo está mal y se
preocupan normal porque no podemos vivir
desconectados del resto por eso nosotros
tenemos que cuidar nuestro mundo este
mundo que tanto nos costó armar y que
tiene que ver con poder vivir mejor sin
depender tanto del afuera por supuesto
que tenemos que todo mejor no somos
tontos
mucho menos egoístas pero para nosotros
el primer mundo debe ser siempre
argentino
[Aplausos]
pero no sólo eso con christina al frente
de la casa rosada- la casa blanca
argentina este país se convirtió en uno
de los más proteccionistas de toda
américa latina y también en un país
donde montar empresas era algo
rematadamente difícil y claro el
resultado de todo esto no se hizo
esperar durante su segundo mandato el
crecimiento fue nulo el déficit público
se disparó la inflación subió al 40% la
inversión se desplomó y de repente otra
vez nada parecía funcionar así que bajo
este panorama es como en diciembre de
2015 los argentinos eligieron a mauricio
macri antiguo presidente del boca
juniors como nuevo presidente de
argentina quiero ser el presidente que
pueda acompañarlos en su crecimiento
el presidente del desarrollo del
potencial de cada argentino
[Música]
la llegada de macri
el primer año de macri al frente de
argentina no fue nada pero que nada
fácil claro sí al terrible estado en el
que cristina fernández de kirchner dejó
el país le añadimos todos los efectos de
las reformas por ejemplo la reducción de
los subsidios a la electricidad al gas
natural porque las reformas no generan
frutos inmediatos es fácil entender que
los primeros meses fuesen tan
complicados atentos
en 2016 el país sufrió una dura recesión
con una caída del pib del 2 6% la
inflación se acercó al 40% aumentó la
pobreza el desempleo el déficit y la
deuda externa
en otras palabras no faltaron
oportunidades para garantizarle a macri
éste era acaso el cambio prometido bien
ya hemos dicho que las reformas no
tienen por qué tener resultados
inmediatos pero al final llegan
por fin en 2017 la economía argentina
está dando síntomas de mejora
es probable que el crecimiento de este
año supere el 3% y el apetito inversor
ya es más que evidente
[Música]
si así es parece que argentina puede
estar llegando a la salida de un largo
túnel
[Música]
aquí
de momento estos resultados le han dado
a macri el gran triunfo electoral que
hemos visto ahora bien qué es lo que
hizo exactamente este presidente pues
básicamente reducir todas esas
regulaciones y políticas tal como
decirlo disparatadas y antieconómicas
[Música]
el nuevo gobierno se puso pronto manos a
la obra no había tiempo que perder
nada más llegar elimino los controles de
divisas permitió que los inversores
extranjeros pudieran repatriar sus
beneficios eliminó la mayoría de los
incomprensibles impuestos a la
exportación y redujo los subsidios y las
restricciones a las importaciones todo
con un objetivo argentina tiene que
recuperar la economía productiva
[Aplausos]
también importantísimo por un lado macri
llegó a un acuerdo con parte de los
inversores internacionales a los que
argentina bien pagado en 2001 y con los
que aún se mantenían peleas judiciales
argentina llega a un acuerdo con los
fondos buitre tras 14 años de pugna en
total para cubrir todas las deudas con
los fondos macri ofrece 6 mil 500
millones de dólares el acuerdo implica
una quita del 25 por ciento por otro
lado el nuevo gobierno aprobó una
especie de regularización de amnistía
fiscal que sacó a la luz
atentos ni más ni menos que 117 mil
millones de dólares que los argentinos
tenían en el extranjero y no habían
declarado ojo antes de escandalizarse
pensad que haríais vosotros si tuvierais
miedo a que nuestros ahorros pudieran
ser confiscados por el gobierno a veces
no sólo es una cuestión de pagarme los
impuestos cuando los estados no tienen
seguridad jurídica es muy fácil que el
dinero simplemente huya el caso amigos
es que con todas estas medidas el
gobierno de macri consiguió que el
dinero volviera a fijarse en argentina y
desde entonces se ha producido toda una
lluvia de dinero que por ejemplo está
disparando el sector inmobiliario o la
venta de coches estamos batiendo récords
más de 780 mil autos vendidos al día de
hoy y lo más importante
de camiones eso significa que la
producción se está moviendo que la
construcción se está moviendo mauricio
macri vamos que el motor nunca mejor
dicho parece haber vuelto a arrancar
volkswagen invertirá 650 millones de
dólares para modernizar plantas en
argentina
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero una pregunta amigos realmente
creéis que está siendo todo tan modélico
tan bonito pues espérate un momento
porque lo cierto es que hasta ahora las
reformas han sido muy pero que muy
graduales y con un alcance bastante
corto algo que a pesar de los resultados
electorales y de todas estas llamadas a
descorchar el champán han puesto en
alerta a muchos expertos a la hora de la
verdad por el momento no ha hecho
demasiado más allá de apartar al
kirchnerismo del poder que no es poco'
aunque ha dicho que estas elecciones son
el aval para las reformas no se sabe muy
bien en qué consiste en qué quiere hacer
carlos rodríguez braun pero por qué
tanta desconfianza pues porque a pesar
de las reformas que hemos visto parece
que a este gobierno le está costando
superar algunas de las típicas
adicciones de los gobiernos argentinos
por ejemplo el gasto público no sólo no
se ha reducido sino que sigue subiendo y
subiendo lo que ha provocado entre otras
cosas que la deuda exterior se dispare
en este breve tiempo en más de 50 mil
millones de dólares
y eso no es todo los impuestos siguen
por las nubes el banco central continúa
financiando al gobierno con nuevo dinero
esto es monetizando deuda y según el
último informe 'doing business' que mide
la facilidad para hacer negocios en un
país argentina sigue en la cola
concretamente en el puesto 116 eso sí
para ser justos podemos decir que hasta
ahora macri ha tenido dos buenas excusas
primero que han pasado poco tiempo y
segundo que su posición política en el
congreso en el senado eran muy débiles
ahora tras las últimas elecciones todo
eso se ha terminado
[Música]
una agenda reformista
parece que tras su aplastante triunfo
electoral el presidente macri lo tiene
claro entramos en una etapa de
reformismo permanente argentina no tiene
que parar y no tienen que tenerle miedo
a las reformas porque reformarse es
crecer evolucionar progresar
mauricio macri por delante le queda una
tarea complicada pero cuáles son
realmente sus prioridades pues
fundamentalmente amigos al principio
algo que pueda ser tan impopular como
necesario reducir el déficit público y
controlar la inflación lo que en última
instancia son cosas relacionadas luego
conseguir que argentina vuelva a ser un
país competitivo y atractivo para
invertir para lograrlo ha prometido
aprobar una reforma fiscal que reduzca
los impuestos a las empresas una reforma
laboral que facilite la contratación y
más acuerdos de libre comercio argentina
y chile- firman el más ambicioso acuerdo
de libre comercio en 20 años luego
también la reforma de las pensiones la
reforma educativa a las infraestructuras
si podemos decir que a macri le queda
mucho trabajo si quiere cumplir con las
altísimas expectativas que se han
depositado en él
[Música]
en cualquier caso parece que sí que esta
vez un nuevo tiempo político y económico
ha comenzado para argentina una buena
muestra de ello lo vemos en la apuesta
de macri por lograr reducir la pobreza
formalizando y extendiendo la propiedad
entre los más desfavorecidos argentina
entrega certificados de vivienda a 1,5
millones de personas de villas miseria
el gobierno de macri les dará los
documentos para acceder a agua y luz de
forma legal de esto por cierto de cómo
combatir la pobreza hablaremos en un
próximo vídeo pero ahora la pregunta es
se pondrá a este país de moda si
profundiza en las reformas y consigue
aprovechar todas las oportunidades como
por ejemplo la industria del litio de la
que también nos hemos hablado aquí no me
cabe la menor duda pero qué pensáis
vosotros conseguir a argentina
convertirse en un motor para
latinoamérica déjanos tu respuesta en
los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y no olvides
suscribirte al canal un saludo y hasta
la próxima
quiero ser el presidente que pueda
acompañarlos en su crecimiento
el presidente del desarrollo del
potencial de cada argentino
se iguala
[Música]
[Aplausos]